[Music]
she had always had an interest in the
royal family oh the irony that's a 15
year old a Megan Marco on a bus tour in
London in 1996 a typical teenager back
then little did she know she wouldn't
just meet the Queen one day they would
be family it's a famous meeting now
between Megan and the Queen at
Buckingham Palace when she took tea with
the Queen and she'd even been its
practice to drink tea properly the
Cawley's gave her the Royal Seal of
Approval because I'm from the States you
don't grow up with the same
understanding of of the royal family and
so while I now understand very clearly
person a global interest there
the soon-to-be duchess of Sussex got her
first taste of the UK while travelling
through Europe with her best friend's
family
checking out the sights in Brussels and
leaving her mark in Switzerland yeah
that says star to be kind of prophetic
right meanwhile her future prince was
just 12 years old in 1996 and coming to
grips with the fact that his parents
were officially divorcing but while the
world already knew all about Harry Megan
was just getting started
you can already see her early ambassador
skills charming the locals while
learning to speak French
[Music]